نعم جلال وانتم تحدثتم عن صور الاقمار
الصناعيه وماذا اظهرت نحن نعطيكم صوره
المكان الاكبر الذي حدثت فيه انهيارات
ارضيه وانشقاقات ارضيه مرعبه ومهوله
نستطيع ان نعطيكم عبر كاميرا الجزيره
الطائره صوره هذه الانشقاقات الارضيه نحن
في منطقه تبعد عن مدينه هاتاي 20 كيلومتر
عن المركز مدينه انطاكيا هذه هذا المكان
حدثت فيه انشقاقات ارضيه وصخريه مرعبه في
هذا المكان هناك
في احد الاماكن عمق اكثر من ثلاثين اكثر
من 30 متر تحت الارض هناك صخور طبقات
صخريه ظهرت
نزلت في هذا الوادي الذي حصل جراء الزلزال
الذي حصل قبل ثمانيه ايام نحن في
الحقول الزيتون في هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه
زراعيه منطقه التون اوزو هذه المنطقه
الزراعيه في معظمها هناك تشققات صغيره
وكبيره هذا هو التشقق الاكبر الذي حصل في
المنطقه وهو تشقق مرعب حقيقه ومشهده غير
طبيعي
الاهالي القريه قريه تبهان هي على مسافه
تقريبا 300 او 500 متر من هذا المكان
قالوا لنا تحدثنا الى مختار القريه قال
مختار القريه ان
استيقظنا على صوت انفجار مهول جدا وتوقعنا
ان قنبله او صاروخا سقطت في الارض بالقرب
من القريه ثم عندما خرجنا الى الشوارع وكل
سكان القريه خرجوا جراء هذا الانفجار كما
وصفوه وجدوا ان الدخان يتصاعد وهو في
الحقيقه الاتربه تتصاعد نتيجه الانهيارات
الارضيه ولذلك سكان هذه القريه معظمهم
غادر القريه خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
ويمكن ان تحدثه هذه الهزات الارتداديه في
القريه وفي المنطقه هناك عشرين بيت سقط
عشرين بنايه في هذه القريه سقطت جراء هذا
هذه الانشقاقات التي حصلت في المكان عن
شاهدت طفل قبل قليل عمره ربما عشر سنوات
قال ان هناك
انفجار حصل في هذا المكان نحن استيقظنا
على الانفجار وخرجنا الى الشوارع لا نعرف
الى اين نذهب وفي الحقيقه هو هذا تصدع
الزلزال الذي حصل في المنطقه وهو كما قلت
تصدع كبير جدا وليس هو التصدع الوحيد هناك
عده اماكن في هذه القرى والاوديه
القريبه من هذا المكان فيها تصدعات لكن
هذا هو التصدع الاكبر الذي حصل في
القريه نحن نعلم انها طاي هي المدينه
الاكبر التي تضررت بهذا الزلزال والخسائر
هي الاكبر الذي حصلت في تركيا هي في مدينه
هاتاي هناك بحسب
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه التي
تفحصت المنازل قالت انه هناك اكثر من 29
بيت تم فحصه هناك
6300 بيت على الاقل يجب ازالتها بالكامل
هناك 2000 بنايه
ازالها الزلزال بالكامل اي ان الخسائر
كبيره جدا
العجيب ان سكان هذه القريه والتي ربما هي
اقل ضررا من
مدينه انطاكيا نزحوا الى مدينه انطاكيا
التي اصيبت بالضرر الكبير خوفا من هذا
المشهد الذي نقف امامه هو مشهد التصدعات
الارضيه يخافون ان تبتلع الارض بيوتهم
نتيجه هذا المشهد الذي يشاهدونه وهناك
طبعا الكثير من البيوت المتصدعه نحن
شاهدنا مختار القريه يسكن في خيمه امام
منزله وكذلك بقيه سكان
هذه القريه قريه تبهان عدد عدد سكانها
خمسه الاف
معظمهم نزح من المدينه والبقيه الباقيه
تسكن الخيم وهناك مشهد رعب وحقيقه هذه
المنطقه اصبحت منطقه مزار
للتعجب من البلدات والقرى القريبه من هذا
المكان يصلون الى هذه المنطقه لمشاهده هذا
ما احدثه الزلزال في في هذه المنطقه وهو
مشهد غير معلوف مشهد حقيقه مرعب
الخوف الاكبر بالنسبه لسكان هذه القريه
والقرى المجاوره هو من الهزات الارتداديه
ربما تاتي هزه يقولون ان الهزات
الزلزال احدث خلخله في الارض وفي المنازل
في هذه المنطقه خلخله كبيره ربما تاتي هزه
ارتداديه وتحدث
ايضا اضرارا مشابهه لهذه الاضرار وكما قلت
الخوف من ان تبتلع الارض هذه المنازل هذا
المشهد هو الذي اوحى لسكان هذه القريه
بهذه الافكار ان الارض من الممكن ان تبتلع
منازلهم
الحقيقه معظم السكان الان خارج
هذه القريه والقرى المجاوره ايضا هجرها
وبداوا يخرجون اتباعا كل اخبار التي
يتابعونها عن هزات الارتداديه بالنسبه لهم
هي اخبار مخيفه مرعبه لا احد يبات ينام في
منزله حتى الذين بيوتهم لم يصيبها ضرر
جراء هذا الزلزال
ينامون في منازلهم ينامون اما في الخيم
اما في السيارات واما غادروا هذه المنطقه
الى
باتجاه مدينه انطاكيا التي تبعد كما قلت
عشرين كيلو متر وهي ايضا مدينه الاكبر
نكبه في تركيا مدينه انطاكيا
الضرر فيها نسبه الوفيات فيها هي الاعلى
جراء هذا الزلزال ونسبه الضرر الذي اصاب
المباني هو الاعلى الذي اصاب
البنايات هناك بحسب احصاءات اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه قالت ان هناك سته الاف
منزل يجب ازالتها متضرره بشكل جزئي يجب
ازالتها وهي تعني ان هناك
33,000 وحده سكنيه يجب ازاله
منازلهم هذا يعني ان هناك
33,000 اسره اصبحت تعيش في العراق بلا
منزل هذا بعيدا عن ان هناك
المنزل الفي بنايه على الاقل في هذه
الالفي بنايه هناك 12,000 شقه سكنيه هذه
تدمرت ومعظم الضحايا هم من هؤلاء الالفي
بنايه الذين سقطوا خلال
جراء الزلزال الذي حصل قبل ثمانيه ايام
حقيقه
صور الدمار ومشاهد الدمار هنا مختلفه عن
بقيه المناطق وربما فيها فيها
لم نبالغ هو حاله من الرعب
عندما تشاهد هذا المنظر وتشاهد
الطبقات الصخريه قد ظهرت هناك ثلاثين متر
عمق
نزلت
الشرق عمقه 30 متر تحت الارض هو مشهد مرعب
وغير طبيعي بالتاكيد وكانها وديان تشكلت
في هذه الحقول لابد انها ستخضع ايضا
لدراسات جيولوجيه لاحقا لمعرفه حقيقه ما
حصل شكرا لك عبد العظيم في التون اوزو
لفريق الجزيره على نقل هذه الصوره لتبيان
قوه هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب شرق
تركيا واثر على شمال غرب سوريا شكرا عبد
العظيم